what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
right now there is a report going around
about when we can't expect to see the
spider-man no way home trailer with an
exact release time and if this report is
accurate then fans are about to be very
very happy of course at this point if
you have been keeping up with spider-man
no way home i think everybody knows that
we're expected to see a trailer or
footage at cinemacon which is on monday
now of course here is what fans want to
happen one they want it leaked obviously
somebody wants somebody to secretly
record the trailer and release it to the
public but if that doesn't happen two we
want a description of the trailer which
can definitely happen because the people
inside watching the trailer can just go
online and post it anonymously but as it
turns out we might not actually have to
wait for that as the date and the time
for marvel studios this spider-man no
way home trailer has apparently leaked a
couple of days ago timbo over at the
youtube channel the lords of the long
box told us that the trailer is coming
to the internet on monday august 23rd at
8 00 am not too long after that mikey
sutton posted it to his website
geekoccitymag.com and the report started
to make its way around the internet tim
vo mentioned it during his show and i've
actually spoken to timbo plenty of times
before in the past so i reached out to
him and i asked him what exactly he
heard and what he told me is that he has
a reliable source who has told him
information in the past that has been
accurate that has told him when to
expect the trailer which like i said is
this upcoming monday at 8am and he
believes this to be accurate since his
source has been reliable and the source
gave him an actual specific time now the
one thing i had a question about is that
i knew sony's panel didn't start till at
night time but tim vo seems to think
that it's going to be a similar
situation to what happened at d23 we
will get a small glimpse of what's to
come and at cinemacon closed to the
public they will see what the internet
is going to see but they'll also see a
lot more perhaps a trailer plus footage
or just a longer trailer and who knows
what sony is going to release to the
public at first it could be a 15 second
teaser hopefully not hopefully it's at
least a minute but we'll have to wait
and see on that and the logic is kind of
here on this if sony and of course
marvel studios since they're working
together but mostly sony as the
president of marketing assad ayaz has
stated that sony is handling most of it
sony knows that fans are going to talk
about what they saw they know that press
is going to be there and they're going
to talk about that as well and they know
that even though security precautions
can be taken there of course is always
the possibility that somebody could
actually record footage of what they saw
and release it online anonymously so if
sony did want to get a jump on these
leaks and description links getting out
they would release it beforehand that
would be the smart move and of course
sony does usually release things early
on in the morning now spider-man no way
home may be different because let's just
face it this film is different it's
bigger if all three spider-man truly are
in the movie this movie could literally
break records of avengers end game and
if i'm sony and i wish i were because i
would release the trailer already but if
i'm sony i'm definitely releasing the
footage before fans have an opportunity
to release it themselves via leaks they
want to be the ones to release it they
don't want their fate controlled by
leaks they want to show us what they
want to show us so hopefully this report
is true and we do get this monday
morning i'm just repeating what i heard
this is not my scoop it's coming from
timbo at lords of the lomboks if you
love comics he has a great channel you
should check him out and like i've been
saying for the past week or so they are
definitely going to show something
spider-man no way home related at
cinemacon so even if the trailer doesn't
drop we're going to be getting something
at the very least a description and if
we get this then it really shouldn't be
too long after when they actually decide
to drop the no way home trailer so
regardless i do think we're in the end
game now not to mention a lot of people
online like big screen leaks and some
people from the mcu's direct are all
teasing information and news about the
trailer and some of them are saying that
we can wait two days which equals monday
so it does seem like a fair amount of
people are stating monday is the day the
trailer day but despite all of these
reports i still want to keep my
expectations at just a description
because that way if something happens
and sony decides not to release any
footage or a trailer i'm not going to be
too disappointed but again it does look
like monday is the day and i'm sure
everybody is just stoked let me know how
excited you are in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news don't
forget to follow me on twitter and
instagram for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof